qu'est ce qu'on attend
il faut que la boule nous appelle
qu'elle dit contre google
nous donne le signal tv route on coud
jacquet oui parce que moi j'ai pu bras
c'est la méthode de force chez le psy je
n'ai jamais dit des gens chez naughty
jamais
allée nouveau leader
mais dès
mardi le terrain c'est pas mais en tout
cas il n'est pas mort de fin d'année
tiens je suis aussi là je vais peut-être
coloscopie avec comme quoi
y'a là
soldats italiens
allez le tgv c'est quoi le tgv le tgv
qui ponctuent coque du touch
pas tout à fait la cour
photo p
quand tu vas jouer à los toros avec
pilar viendra gare
et mme berger
et voilà et derrière le jabot ya le cas
et ça y est
il avait vu juste